[Music]
as the roads aren't safe enough and I
was in recovery and they took my house
my husband and I bit here
recovery recovery and become a mini
nanny month which is your favorite let
me I don't use one or the other
okay that's moving I might think that
and what do you do for money do you pick
up men sometimes
no I'm psycho yeah
did you see your son yeah yeah I don't
know we just I don't know he's supposed
to be and she's been a lot you know
something
but he's was simply getting out in and
just I don't know it's a long story you
know yeah it's just when they took my
son you know they were married a
recovery he he we loved him and they
took everything for me so I was in jail
because he had drugs in the house and
they took my son and then they took all
my stuff in my house and then they put
me in prison and then all my stuff got
taken away from me so and my son too and
then my husband's happy here downtown at
the wine cart so I haven't seen him ever
since and my son I haven't seen for 10
years and he better get started coming
to see me when eternity and then they
went to jail my life I've always been
self-supporting taking care of myself
you know I don't I don't go with that
because I feel that sir give it to
myself
TBT that people shouldn't even think
about each other like but I can't change
anything with Oh God so you know a lot
of times it's just real stressful
because there's really nobody to talk to
they're ready don't want to talk about
realities because I'm trying to evade
you know but I said you kind of hated
it's gonna be there in the end you know
I never cried before that's what almost
killed me was an emotional breakdown you
know I was always so serious like get my
life together you don't have some kids
and somebody in my life I have to take
trying to make sure my mom would be okay
key see that I'm a good husband my
grandma because she didn't have one at
all you know and then women with
children that's how I learned that women
with children other men don't wanna me
and especially they have two more
children with different man you know so
my grandma had tweet tweeted from
father's image my mom and only had words
so I saw that and so I waited 10 years
to have my kids you know you know yeah
big world can curse you know just
basically Jesus you know he's what I
worry about the most
I don't want to get it yeah so be here I
just try to take care of myself to do
the best that I can without getting into
too much but people just don't
understand how not just deal oh my god
he shouldn't still he says don't still
far reason people maybe cuz I'm so crazy
you know it saying you're stealing from
yourself nobody else IDO so did you get
a job once oh yeah that was justice yeah
I was worried Chuck job boy type
oh yeah heads up I try to work for them
for the dog catcher right details
spirituality rules I didn't I didn't
know nothing about spirituality
chhankata sure so I kind of reduced by
that if you do it it's all true you need
a fatty okay